j'arrêtais pas pendant le tournage je me
dis rien à faire avec ce gamin font
envie de le prendre le cassé en deux et
puis voilà ces gens là haut donne
beaucoup d'amour rice et décourage
jamais c'est vraiment incroyable
c'est fou parce que c'est vrai qu'on a
on réagit comme vous enfin comme est
d'ailleurs rod vous deux vous avez l'air
gentil garçon comme ça
comment vous avez trouvé 2 une telle
enfin comment vous avez travaillé avec
emmanuel pour trouver cette cette
violence est trash qu'il a du boulot
tout d'abord grâce aussi au coach ouais
j'ai bien appeler le texte j'ai bien
compris bien l'histoire et grâce à
emmanuel sa catherine deneuve grâce à
benoît france art et sara forestier et
grâce à moi j'imagine mais vous êtes
comme lui vous du report semblait pas
dans la vie rassurez moi vous n'êtes pas
j'ai pas du tout violent un garçon très
douces à garçon très doué mais lol le
film est écrit comme ça les dialogues
été écrit comme ça on sentait bien qu'il
y avait une vraie violence et
voilà je crois que ça doit être c'est
difficile j'imagine pour la première
expérience mais en même temps c'était
vraiment écrit comme ça
pour la première fois en 68 édition le
jury aura comme vous le savez deux
présidents alors en ces temps de crise
le festival peut-il se le permettre deux
présidents se sont de suite dans un
palace de chauffeur de voiture
officielle de parts de homard à chaque
repas je ne sais combien de kilos de
viennoiseries au petit déjeuner mesdames
et messieurs chers et irene khan
jeudi qu'un nouvel ouverte la 68e
festive au deccan bien fini le monde
ouais je trouve qu'on aurait pu se lever
pour catherine deneuve on aurait pu
voilà on regretter c'était mon avis sur
la cette cérémonie qui était
merveilleuse mais je me serais levé pour
catherine deneuve
ok d'accord voilà c'est passé s'est
passé mais il peut plus revenir
voilà nous sommes en direct avec les
présidents du jury du festival les
frères coen joel et ethan messieurs tout
d'abord qui est acquis et joël mois
cette année le moche c'est joël un
bassin pas l'accueil
oui justement ça va être trop difficile
de présider à 2 non ça va on est souvent
d'accord rosso dépend sur quoi est toute
façon c'est moi l'aîné donc c'est moi
qui décide maman joël une daube désordre
je vais déjà toutefois s'il te plaît à
vous est venu avec votre mère nom est un
est venu et que sa mère moi je suis
assez grand pour me défendre tout seul
tu as entendu moment joël y continuent
vaille aux sétois le fayot et oui le
plus dur cette année ça va être de
départager les présidents du jury
julianne moore car si un prix qui vous
avez vous a été décerné l'année dernière
pour le film de david cronenberg qui
s'appelle match de store et vous n'aviez
pas pu le recevoir ce prix alors il faut
nous expliquer vous étiez ou qu'est ce
qui s'est passé j'étais à cannes
j'étais venu avec l'oréal j'étais resté
presque une semaine je ravel avec marcq
n'diaye et puis ensuite nous étions en
compétition avec mal son geste aux c'tés
mercredi et je suis rentré chez moi
c'était le mémorial day week end aux
états unis donc nous avons mis les
enfants en voiture avec nos chiens on
est parti dans notre maison à la plage
et je plier des serviettes je nettoyais
hier matin à celle qui m'a dit vous avez
rempli notre actrice à cannes je n'avais
pas le temps de revenir l'un de vos
confrères
sean penn a trouvé un moyen beaucoup
plus original devient alors c'est un
avis aussi mais ils étaient bloqués en
haïti il est très engagé pour haïti sean
penn
ils étaient bloqués il avait une galère
pour venir à cannes et du coup qui
passait hier par haïti françois hollande
françois hollande qui terminait sa
tournée dans les caraïbes en haïti la
rencontre et sean penn qui l'a dit je
sais pas comment la can du côlon lui a
proposé de monter dans l'avion
présidentiel s'il a été acceptée par
sean penn
du coup sean penn et à révol gratuit on
le lisait n'y a pas assez payés il est
arrivé à paris ce matin et puis il est
attendu à cannes ce soir ou demain matin
donc si jamais sean penhale à lambert
wilson
demain ce sera grâce à air hollande one
merci la france j'appelle c'est le grand
pote de marquer l'essai le grand paul du
président a été très très grands pôles
il avait beaucoup pour pour haïti et
vous deviez initialement être dans la
délégation de canaliser ou l'avait
proposé je crois oui parce que j'ai
présenté le film que j'ai vu un
documentaire sur sur haïti qui va passer
sur la malle le 20 mai est en fête
bah oui je pouvais pas je répété hier la
cérémonie de ce soir mais j'aurais
beaucoup aimé faire passer du voyage et
la dea pour lui montrer quelques milles
quartier machar julianne moore je
profite de votre présence sur notre
plateau pour vous dire que vous êtes une
comédienne que j'adore notamment parce
que vous avez participé un de mes films
cultes le big lebowski des frères coen
qui préside cette 68e édition
absolument je l' ai vu une douzaine de
fois je suis complètement dingue de ce
film il est d'ailleurs ressorti dans les
salles la semaine dernière j'ai un
service à vous demander les frères coen
sont à l'hôtel martinez j'ai vu ce matin
pendant leur petit déjeuner un des deux
avait un oeuf coque et l'autre des oeufs
brouillés et je cherche une petite
phrase pour pouvoir les approcher je
suis très timide qu'est-ce que je peux
faire pour pour aller les voir
conseillez moi vous pouvez dire ce que
moi je leur ai dit dans ces marchés